[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
tulsa oklahoma becomes the latest
location in a string of mass shootings
how much more carnage are we willing to
accept
how many more innocent american lives
must be taken before we say enough how
lawmakers are calling for change and is
johnny depp headed back to court why the
aclu is asking for 86 thousand dollars
from the actor plus the murdoch murder
mystery why investigators hope to exhume
the body of alec murdoch's former
housekeeper and later he doesn't scare
me i've seen donald trump make it
nothing michael avenatti can say will
scare me michael avenatti is sentenced
to prison time after stealing thousands
from former client stormy daniels long
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to
[Music]
host ryan coast
four people were killed this week when a
gunman opened fire in a tulsa oklahoma
hospital this comes just one week after
the deadly elementary school shooting in
uvalde texas
investigators say gunman michael lewis
legally purchased an ar-15 style rifle
the same day as the shooting on
wednesday afternoon he entered the saint
francis hospital campus where he shot
and killed two doctors a receptionist
and a patient investigators say the
shooter blamed the victim dr preston
phillips for causing him pain following
a recent back surgery the other victims
include dr stephanie hussein
receptionist amanda glenn and patient
william love at a press conference on
thursday tulsa police officers explained
what happened when they arrived to the
scene
officers entered the building on the
first floor and made their way to the
second floor based on the information
they received
while on the second floor of the bass
building officers began yelling tulsa
police
this is something that we trained to do
as officers were calling out tulsa
police
and advancing
towards a suspect location they heard a
gunshot
we believe that was the final gunshot
with the suspect taking his own life law
enforcement across the nation is dealing
with increased violence among
people is yet another act of violence
upon an american city
president joe biden ecked the sentiments
thursday evening calling for change in
gun related policy following a multitude
of mass shootings in recent weeks
after columbine
after sandy hook
after charleston after orlando after las
vegas
after parkland
nothing has been
done this time that can't be true
this time we must actually do something
the issue we face is one of conscience
and common sense
for so many of you at home
i want to be very clear
this is not about taking away anyone's
guns
it's about philip not about vilifying
gum gun owners
in fact we believe we should be treating
responsible gun owners as an example of
how every gun owner should behave
i respect the culture and the tradition
and the concerns of lawful gun owners
at the same time
the second amendment like all other
rights is not absolute
joining us today is legal analyst matt
mengino and co-host terry austin matt
are there laws in the books right now
that you think create greater chances
for the wrong people to obtain guns
well you know
brian what i think is not so much what's
on the books right now but what isn't on
the books right now uh when we look at
this tragedy in in oklahoma uh you know
and it touches all of us i mean i i had
a niece who delivered a child at that
hospital so so we all have and we're all
being touched more and more by this but
you know what's the reason to have an
ar-15 it's not for hunting it's it's
it's not for for sport um what's it for
it's to kill human beings why should uh
you know a young person as we saw in in
um in these other incidents have access
to an ar-15 be able to lawfully buy we
need more uh
scrutiny of background checks and other
laws you know common sense laws that can
protect the public from people who
shouldn't have
firearms
in the first place yeah and i know that
your sentiments are echoed in yavaldi
texas where the bodies of these children
were so brutally damaged they need to
give dna just to identify them for a
similar style of weapon terry president
biden said that the second amendment
right to bear arms is not absolute so
how does the united states fairly and
legally curtail that right for
everyone's safety
well i think they have to do a little
bit of what matt was talking about and i
think there are some steps we can do
first of all they should ban assault
weapons no one needs an automatic or
semi-automatic weapon they should also
ban bump stocks that increase the speed
of the bullets they should ban
high-capacity magazine that increases
the amount of the ammunition you don't
need all of that and obviously
background checks waiting periods
increase the age all of that done and
it's done on a federal level yeah it
blows my mind maybe it's the canadian in
me that there are some people in this
country who can't buy a beer at a bar
but can buy an ar-15 that doesn't make
sense to me but like you said maybe
there's some changes that need to happen
switching gears now to the april mass
shooting out of california's capital
city as a fourth suspect is now in
custody six people were killed and 12
more injured when multiple gunmen opened
fire in sacramento investigators believe
the shooting was gang related last
weekend imaltuli payton was arrested in
connection to the deadly shooting
investigators say he was arrested in las
vegas with the help of the fbi and las
vegas metro police department he now
faces charges including possession of a
handgun and three counts of murder
police have arrested brothers deandre
and smiley martin as well as
davion
dawson in relation to the shooting
still ahead on law and crime daily new
developments involving disgraced south
carolina attorney alec murdoch and the
death of his former housekeeper but
first johnny jett is slammed with
another lawsuit why the aclu is asking
for more than 80 000 worth of
reimbursements
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
american civil liberties union better
known as the aclu files suit against
johnny depp seeking more than 80
thousand dollars in reimbursement for
the organization's involvement in the
defamation case
in court documents filed back in april
aclu representatives say in part quote
the aclu produced three witnesses
including its executive director for
over 16 hours of depositions along the
way mr depp rejected numerous
compromises to minimize the burden and
expenses on the aclu and its employees
the lawsuit claims the organization
complied with a subpoena reviewing
nearly 8 000 documents the aclu played a
significant role in the defamation suit
as heard pledged part of her divorce
settlement from depp to the organization
her later testified she only paid 1.3
million of the 3.5 million pledge to the
aclu as a result of depths litigation
members of the organization also helped
draft
out helped her draft sorry the
washington post op-ed that would become
the basis for adept's defamation claims
as part of his video deposition aclu
chief counsel terence dougherty admitted
dep's name was part of the original
draft
and isn't it true that miss heard's
advisers initially revised the draft to
remove
any reference
to ms heard's marriage or divorce i
recall a number of email communications
back and forth among
aclu personnel and ms herds
attorneys
where they were
suggesting edits to the op-ed relating
to
matters covered in the nda
and then is it also true that there were
some
at the aclu
who expressed their belief
[Music]
that excising those references to
her marriage and divorce
from johnny depp
made
the op-ed less impactful correct
um it is correct that is correct
she was referring at least in part to
johnny depp correct
now based on my review of prior drafts
of the op-ed i knew that they were that
that she was referring to johnny depp in
her marriage
all right terry the aclu is suing johnny
depp for their expenses in connection
with the trial any chance they'll
actually be able to win that argument
you know i think they're going to settle
it out of court at the end of the day
death team is saying there is no
requirement under new york law they're
looking at new york law because aclu is
a new york corporation and even if there
had been a requirement to pay back or
reimburse the aclu you know they spent a
lot of time they hired these outside
lawyers they reviewed these documents
they produced these documents they
produced witnesses so even if they
wanted some of that money back it is
exorbitant and it might be deemed
unreasonable so i do think at the end of
the day they're going to end up
resolving it out of court yeah now matt
i get why the acu is suing donny depp
but they helped draft amber heard's
washington post op-ed so couldn't depp
have a counter-suit against them
well brian is certainly possible um and
we know that johnny depp isn't afraid to
to
stick his nose in a fight he he's
learning his way around the courtroom
pretty well uh and he's had success uh
with this case against amber heard uh i
don't know i mean what we know is that
certainly the aclu
attempted to to minimize
any reference to johnny depp in their
advice to to amber heard but they're
relying on amber heard telling them the
truth about what her relationship was
like with her husband and other partners
well matt at the very least johnny depp
understands hearsay so maybe he takes
that knowledge and points in the
direction they aclu but we'll see how
that plays out switching gears now to
california where actor and comedian bill
cosby once again faces sexual abuse
allegations in a civil trial cosby is
being sued by now 64 year old judy huth
hooth claims cosby forced her to perform
a sex act with him at the playboy
mansion in the 1970s when she was just a
teenager cosby claims there is no
evidence hooth was ever at the mansion
when the alleged sexual assault occurred
his attorneys say playboy provided the
mansion's visitor log and calendar from
the mid-70s which allegedly shows no
record of who's visiting during that
time cosby's attorneys say hooth has
also
changed her story saying she was 16 at
the time and that the incident happened
in february 1975 a year later than she
originally claimed cosby is now is no
stranger to sexual assault charges in
2018 the comedian was convicted for
drugging and molesting andrea constant
but qazi was released just two years
later from prison that was 11 months ago
after the pennsylvania supreme court
overturned his conviction because of a
previous non-prosecution agreement the
84 year old does not plan to attend the
trial in person because of health
reasons
coming up on law and crime daily months
after a conviction michael avenatti is
sentenced in federal court
plus the murdoch murder mystery could
the body of alec murdoch's late
housekeeper soon be exhumed
[Music]
welcome back we'll have capital gavel
coverage of a new case starting next
week on law and crime it's the florida
trial of daniel redlich of danielle
redlich a woman facing charges for the
murder of her stepfather turned husband
redlick is accused of fatally stabbing
her 65 year old husband michael in 2019.
michael was previously married to
redlich's mother he also worked as the
director of the university of central
florida's sports business management
program prosecutors offered redlich a
plea deal two years ago to plead guilty
to manslaughter charges but redlich
rejected it she's facing second-degree
murder and tampering with evidence
charges redlink called 9-1-1 the day
after she and michael had a fight where
she told the dispatcher her husband
stabbed himself that 911 call gives us a
glimpse inside what can be expected in
the trial as it moves forward starting
monday
what's going on at 12 31 simple drive
i believe my husband is disney
okay
and why do you believe he's defeated
because he's been
i i just he's stiff and he's did you
wanted you might have a heart attack i
don't know
okay did you just find him
no actually what happened last night
it happened last night
correct
so did you find him this morning because
i know you said that you believed it
happened last night did you see him last
night was he okay or was
he was not okay last night we had we had
altercation and
he stabbed himself and i ran into the
bathroom and then i came out i tried to
help him and i thought he was just lying
in blood
and then
i tried to help him
correct yes
a disgraced south carolina lawyer facing
a slew of unrelated charges has reached
a settlement agreement with the family
of his former housekeeper who died at
his home in what he called a trip and
fall accident four years ago alec
murdoch has agreed to pay over four
million dollars to the sons of his
former housekeeper gloria stattersfield
in the wrongful death lawsuit filed last
year satterfield's family claimed they
never saw any money that was supposed to
be paid by murdoch's insurance company
after her death in 2018. earlier this
year murdoch confessed to diverting four
million dollars meant for the status
fields into his own account south
carolina's law enforcement division is
also hoping to find more answers about
statterfield's death and how and have
requested her body be exhumed murdoch is
facing more than 70 unrelated charges
for alleged financial crimes and other
charges related to a scheme to commit
suicide and defraud his insurance
company murdoch's accused of stealing
nearly eight and a half million dollars
from his former clients investigators
are also still working to solve the
murder of murdoch's wife and son no one
has been charged in their 2021 shooting
deaths
terry it seems that the settlements
agreement is the easy part and probably
the hard part is do you think the status
field will be able to collect all that
money
you know i think they're going to have
to get in line we have seen that murdock
is in so much trouble in so many
different areas that he has defrauded
people and taken people's money and you
know obviously there are the deaths that
surround him
but the money is now being managed by a
receiver and so there are other
creditors and the families being very
patient but they know they're going to
have to wait for this receiver to
collect more assets as far as murdock is
concerned and they're going to have to
wait until it's their turn to get paid
so great they have a settlement 4.3
million but getting that money is going
to be very difficult yeah matt maybe
it's the public defender in me but if
criminal charges are brought for status
quos i can already hear the opening
statements uh for murdoch this isn't a
coincidence it's a murder is what i
expect a prosecutor would say but
do you see any evidence to support that
argument
well at this point we we don't but
they're exhuming uh the body of this
woman so that uh
uh a a full autopsy can be done to
determine the actual um you know cause
of death uh and you know this is a
bizarre case uh you know we first you
know he tries to stage his own
uh death then uh you know you know
his wife and daughter i mean wife and
son uh were also uh murdered and now you
have this this case of the housekeeper
but it's not unusual for old cases to
kind of bring new cases to light we saw
it with robert durst
in the cases that we we covered here on
law and crime in the daily you know
that there's smoke there's fire so you
start digging and you find additional
case
yeah could have said it better where
there is smoke there is fire and maybe
this
exhuming of the body finds that fire
when we come back michael avenatti is
sentenced to federal prison how much
time the disgraced attorney will spend
behind bars for stealing thousands of
dollars from former client stormy
daniels
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily four
months after he's convicted on multiple
federal charges disgraced attorney
michael avenatti is sentenced to four
years in prison as law on crime daily
reported avenatti was convicted on
counts of wire fraud and aggravated
identity theft after stealing nearly 300
thousand dollars from former client
stormy daniels daniels an adult film
actress whose real name is stephanie
clifford rose to fame ahead of the 2016
presidential election when allegations
emerged of an affair between her and
then presidential candidate donald trump
daniels later wrote the book full
disclosure about the incident
prosecutors say avenatti took thousands
of dollars from daniels as part of her
book deal advance avenatti made
headlines again when he elected to
represent himself in the case and
questioned daniels as part of
cross-examination right now avenatti is
serving a 30-month prison sentence on a
separate conviction for attempting to
extort more than 20 million dollars from
nike a portion of his latest sentence
will be served concurrently with that
next month he is set to go to trial in
california for additional charges
stemming from 10 million dollar
embezzlement allegations
matt i know it's a lot so he's already
facing time on two cases somewhat
concurrent because of the length of time
and has another one coming so can he
serve time for all of these cases at the
same time or will it be one after the
other with this california case coming
up
well uh brian each state has their own
uh sentence guidelines their own
statutes that govern the way sentences
are going to be
imposed by judges there is a lot of
discretion and part of that discretion
in most situations is the question of
consecutive sentencing one sentence
after the other or concurrent sentencing
sentencing at the same time we know that
two of these sentences are currently
running together we'll have to look at
the california case ultimately if he's
convicted and see what their sentence
guidelines say in terms of concurrent or
consecutive sentencing
yeah first two cases in new york this
last one in california he's literally
got cases from coast to coast now terry
when it rains it pours avenatti is
facing charges all across the country do
you think he could try to reach a plea
deal with the remaining charges though
you know i think he better try to a plea
deal as you said he is really facing
charges everywhere across the country
and in fact if he again goes to trial
say he goes to the california trial he
could be deemed guilty yet again and
face more time he's already admitted
that he's made lots of mistakes he
fought back tears he said he's destroyed
his career and his family so he seems to
take some responsibility for his actions
and based on that i think he probably
should face the prosecutors and try to
resolve this last case
especially if you can get that time done
concurrently well thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you